we will now go through two examples of
convergence in probability our first
example is quite trivial we're dealing
with a sequence of random variables yn
that are discrete most of the
probability is concentrated at zero but
there is also a small probability of a
large value because the bulk of the
probability mass is concentrated at zero
it is a good guess that this sequence
converges to zero do we have indeed
converges in probability to zero we need
to check the definition so we fix some
epsilon which is a positive number and
we look at the probability of the event
that our random variable is epsilon or
more away than what we think is the
limit of that sequence we look at that
probability and in this example it is
equal to 1 over N which goes to 0 as n
goes to infinity and this verifies that
indeed in this example yn converges to 0
as n goes to infinity in probability now
we make the following observation if we
are to calculate the expected value of
this random variable what we get is the
following we get a value of 0 with this
probability no contribution to the
expectation but we also get a value of N
squared with probability 1 over N and so
the expected value is equal to n which
actually goes to infinity as n goes to
infinity so we have a situation where
the random variable the sequence of the
random variables converges to zero but
the expectation does not converge to 0
in fact it goes to infinity and this
example serves to make the point that
convergence in probability does not
imply convergence of expectations the
reason is that convergence in
probability has to do with the bulk of
the distribution it only cares that the
tail of the distribution has small
probability on the other hand the
expectation is highly sensitive
to the tail of the distribution it might
be that the tail only has a small
probability but if that probability is
assigned to a very large value then the
expectation will be strongly affected
and can be quite different from the
limit of the random variable our second
example is going to be less trivial and
more interesting consider random
variables that are independent and
identically distributed and whose common
distribution is uniform on the unit
interval so that the PDF takes this form
are these random variables convergent to
something the answer is no and the
reason is that as I increases the
distribution does not change and it does
not get concentrated around a certain
number the distribution remains spread
out over the entire unit interval but
let us look now at some related random
variables let us define yn to be the
minimum of the first end of the axis
that we get so if n equals equals to 4
and we obtain these four values YN would
be equal to this value notice that if we
draw more values then the new values
might be above the minimum in which case
the minimum does not change but we might
also get a value that's below the
minimum in which case the minimum moves
down the only thing that can happen is
that the minimum goes down it cannot go
up and this gives us this inequality so
the random variables yn tend to go down
how far down if n is very large we
expect that we will obtain some X's
whose value happens to be very close to
0 which means that yn will go down to
values that are very close to 0 and this
leads us to conjecture that perhaps yn
does converge to 0 this is always the
first step when dealing with convergence
in probability the first step is to make
an educated guess
about what the limit might be and then
we want to verify that this is indeed
the correct limit to verify that what we
do is we fix some positive Epsilon and
we look for the probability that the
distance of the random variable Y n from
the conjectured limit has a magnitude
that's larger than or equal to Epsilon
and what we need to show is that this
quantity converges to zero as n goes to
infinity no matter what epsilon is now
because yn is a non-negative random
variable this is the same as the
probability that yn is larger than or
equal to Epsilon
now let us distinguish between two cases
if epsilon is bigger than 1 we're asking
for the probability that yn is larger
than or equal to a certain number
epsilon that's out there but this
probability is 0 there is no way that
the minimum of these uniforms will take
a value that's larger than some epsilon
that's larger than 1 so in that case
this quantity is equal to 0 and we are
done but we need to check that this
quantity becomes small no matter what
epsilon is so now let us consider taking
a small epsilon that is some number
that's less than or equal to 1 for that
case let us continue with the
calculation the minimum is going to be
at least epsilon if and only if all of
the random variables are at least
epsilon so this is an equivalent way of
writing this particular event here now
because of Independence this is the
product of the probabilities that each
one of the random variables is larger
than or equal to Epsilon
the probability that X 1 is larger than
or equal to Epsilon can be found as
follows if we have here Epsilon the
probability of being larger than or
equal to epsilon is the probability of
this event here so it's the area of this
rectangle the base of that rectangle is
- epsilon and so we obtain 1 minus
epsilon for this first term but because
the x i's are identically distributed
all the other terms that we multiply are
also the same and so the answer is this
expression here now epsilon is a
positive number so 1 minus epsilon is
strictly less than 1 and when we take
higher powers of a number that's less
than 1 we obtain something that
converges to 0 as n goes to infinity and
that's what we needed to verify since
this is the case for any epsilon we
conclude that the random variables yn
converge to 0 in the sense that we have
defined in probability generalizing from
this example when we want to show
convergence in probability the first
step is to make a guess as to what is
the value that the sequence converges to
in this example that value was equal to
0 once we have made that conjecture then
we write down an expression for the
probability of being Epsilon away from
the conjectured limit and then we
calculate that probability either
exactly as in this example or we try to
bound it somehow and still show that it
goes to 0